[音楽]
ます
みなさん子どもの頃何になりたかったですか
私は幼いころ宇宙人になりたいと思っていた時期がありました
地球の常識から離れたよまったく未知の世界で着てみたいと思っていました
当時母親には朝起きて僕がいなくても心配しなくていいよ
宇宙人に連れて行かれただけだからと伝えていました
母親はそれはさすがに冗談やろうと
放ったそうですが僕はもちろん真剣です
なので宇宙人が少しでも迎えに来やすいようにあえて布団を窓際に敷いて寝ることも
ありました
ただ
中学生になると宇宙人になれなかった場合のことも考えて生きようと思いました
とはいえ
まあ知らない世界への好奇心は残っていたので
高校生のときにはとにかく知らない国に行きたいそんな想いデー
中央アメリカのコスタリカという国に1年間留学しました
愛情深いホストファミリーと友達のおかげでスペイン語も覚え
何者にも代えがたい素晴らしい時間を過ごすことができました
この写真はお気に入りの一枚ですこの表情を見ていると
まあいい留学だったんだなあと改めて思います
このコスタリカ留学は私の人生に大きな影響を与えました
というのも1年という短い流が期間でしたが自分が海外旅行者ではなく
外国人住民になるという体験だったからです
日本から来た外国人であるとはどういうことでしょうか
ドラゴンボールエア
スーパーマリオん
これでね
まあアニメとゲームの国から来た赤ものとして話のネタには事欠きませんでした
しかし
それと同時に自分はコスタリカの人々とは見た目
体験や文化異なるマイノリティでしたから
時にはアジア人に対する偏見にも気がつき
居心地の悪さを感じたこともありました
さらに日本でのせ高校生活を通して自分と同じ日本で生まれ育った
在日コリアンの若者が生まれた国で外国人扱いされ理不尽な差別や偏見に苦しむことが
あると知り
そうした状況は許すことのできない問題だと考えるようになりました
このような高校時代の経験を通して二つのことをはっきりと認識しました
一つ
国籍とルーツの点では自分が日本社会で圧倒的にマジョリティに属しているということ
もうひとつは人間は皆平等であるべきですが
現実には多くの国々においてマジョリティーとマイノリティの間に不平等な関係がある
ということです
ではどうして
国籍やルーツの違いに基づいた差別が[ __ ]のでしょうか
どうすればそうした違いを乗り越えて私たちは共に生きていけるのでしょうか
このような問題意識が私が移民の歴史を学んできた
原動力となっています
され
私がフルブライト奨学生として留学したアメリカ西海岸のロサンゼルスはアメリカ国内
の先住民と移住者に加え
移民とその子孫が都市の発展を支えてきました
20世紀初頭から今日まで多くの日本人が暮らしてきた地域です
日本もかつて多くの労働者を海外に送り出す国でした
その結果第二次世界対戦が始まる前には
ロサンゼルス地域には3万7000人近い
日系人が暮らしていました
ロサンゼルスの移民の歴史を学ぶと
国籍やルーツの違いに基づいた差別の大きな要因の一つは
人種主義であるということがよくわかります
人種主義とは何でしょうか
それは
個人の
つまり私たち一人ひとりの能力や考えなどが
生物学的に遺伝的に決定されると思い込むことです
人種主義者はこのような誤った思い込みに基づいて他者を事故とは違う人種として扱い
た者への差別を
正当化します
私たち人類の dna は99.9%同じですが人種主義はこうした事実を無視します
特に経済状況が悪化したり戦争が起きたりするとき
マジョリティーからのマイノリティに対する人種主義的な差別や
排除の力が強まります
かつてアメリカに移住した日本人移民も人種差別の対象でした
これは
1920年の日本人排斥運動の一端を示すポスターです
日本人がカリフォルニア州を静かに侵略しているというメッセージとドームに
ジャークなイメージの日本人の手が描かれています
このような日本人排斥運動背景に
アメリカ政府は1924年
日本人移民の入国を全面的に禁止します
日本では多くの人が怒りを感じ各地で反米運動が展開されました
もちろん日本人移民にとってもこの出来事は大きなショックでした
当時ロサンゼルスで発行されていたラフ新報という日本語新聞を読む等
日本人移民の禁止はアジア人に対する人種差別の表れであり戦争の恐怖をあおるものだ
と厳しく批判しています
実際にこの17年後
日本とアメリカの間で
戦争が起きます
この移民法は人種差別を背景としていました
一方でこの年のラフ新報の批評はそうした差別を乗り越えるためのヒントも教えてくれ
ます
それらの批評は
当時の日本社会で見られた日本人による中国人や朝鮮人移民に対する差別についても
批判していたからです
1920年代前半日本政府は中国人移民労働者への差別的な取り締まりを強化し一部に
国外退去を命じています
このような動きに対してラフ進歩わー
アメリカ人による日本人排斥と日本人による中国人排斥はどれほど違うというのか
と疑問を投げかけ日本社会に反省を流しています
また1923年に関東大震災が発生したとき
朝鮮人が略奪や放火をしたなどのデマが広まり
それを信じた日本人が多くの次のない朝鮮人移民を殺害しました
こうした事件についてラグ進歩わー
信じるべきではない巷の噂を信じて一般の日本人が勝手に挑戦の人々を捉えてリンチ
するようなことは8番行為といわざるを得ない
とはっきりと批判しています
もちろん全ての日本人移民が日本人自身による差別について批判的であったわけでは
ありません
しかし今紹介しました一部の記事は
日本人移民がアメリカ国内で差別を受けたからこそ日本国内で差別を受けた中国人や
[ __ ]移民に対する共感を持ち
卑劣な差別や暴力に対する憤りを示すものでもありました
このように100年ほど前の日本語新聞を読んでいると
世界をつなぐということは
国籍やルーツの違いを乗り越えて人々が共に生きていくために
互いに共感することなんだと気づかされます
このような歴史的な教訓は
今日の日本社会を考えるうえでも有効です
この数は何を表していると思いますか
これは
日本で暮らす外国人住民のはずです
30年前に比べると2倍以上の247万人乗り
地域社会や経済において高瀬ない存在であり続けています
アジアや南アメリカ出身者も多くかつてそうした地域に移住した日本人の子孫も含まれ
ます
外国籍の子どもたちも日本社会で育っています
しかし
昨年法務省の委託で行われた調査によると
外国人住民の3割が
日本で差別的なことを言われたことがあると答えています
大多数の日本人はこのように外国人住民が日本で経験する差別や不安については
ほとんどしていません
日本社会のマジョリティには外国人住民に対する共感がまだまだ
かけています
ではどうすれば
自分とは違う他者として見なしがちな外国人への共感を社会として育んでいける
でしょうか
そのために必要なことは2つあると思います
一つは
地味な作業ですがやはり
移民の歴史を学ぶということです
海外で外国人になった日本人の歴史そして日本社会を支えてきた外国人の歴史
それらを学ぶことは
日本人か外国人かという社会が作り出した境界線を心の中で取り除くことにつながり
ます
人生のどこかで意味しに触れることで外国にルーツを持つ人々に共感する下地を作る
ことができると私は考えています
しかし
移民の歴史を学ぶという行動は簡単には社会には広がりません
こうした問題にもともと関心のない人が自ら進んで
移民の歴史を学ぶことはないでしょ
加えて日本の学校教育では
移民の歴史んについて学ぶ機会は十分にはありません
一方で
インターネットでは
海外外国にルーツを持つ人々やその歴史について事実に基づかない差別的表現
ヘイトスピーチがあふれており簡単に目に入ってきます
このような情報が氾濫する時代だからこそ
証拠とその分析に裏付けられた移民史を学び
差別を放置しない社会を
気づくことの重要性はますます増しています
私自身は移民史の研究者として今まさにここでやっているように
今の時代だからこそ
印象学ぼうと社会や大学の中で今後も声をあげていきたいと思っています
自分と自分はい民主党は関係がないと
思っている人でも
家族の歴史を調べる中で
親戚や先祖の誰かがかつて海外に移住していたことを知ることだってあるかもしれませ
ん
国連の定義では海外で1年以上暮らした人は長期滞在の移民です
外国人への共感を育むもう一つの方法は
日本の地域社会で暮らす外国人住民と関わるということです
私は
滋賀県で
外国につながる子どもたちの学習支援活動を8年前から続けています
日本語学習や高校進学をサポートするだけでなく
何でも安心して相談できる居場所づくりに取り組んでいます
これはねー
フェルや
ブラジルフィリピンなどにルーツをもつ子どもたちと関わってきました
外国人の親から受ける生活や教育の相談にもスペイン語や英語で対応します
ただ子どもたちとやってることは
勉強だけではありません
こんなこともします
シュッポッポですね
これは
あのまあ30代半ばになってまさか電車ごっこができるとは思っていなかったのでまあ
ありがたいことだなと思っています
これはですね
親睦を深めるために
子どもたちと保護者の方々とバーベキューを楽しんだ時の写真です
このような活動を通して
子どもの状況を理解するだけでなく外国人の親が
日本人と同じ地域社会の住民として
子供のことを思いながら
一生懸命働いていることを身近に知ることができます
私は
研究者になる前
新聞記者として4年間働きました
ある高齢者の介護施設では
介護士として働くインドネシア人女性を取材しました
介護の技術と日本語を覚えながら異国の地で働くということは大変な仕事です
彼女は来日後の半年で体重が15キロ持ちました
それでも頑張る理由を彼女に聞くと
家族のため子どものためと答えてくれました
彼女は日本で高齢者の生活を支えながら
インドネシアで暮らすホットと子供2人の生活も支えていたのです
このような外国に人住民との関わり合いを通して
同じ社会の一員としての教官さらに感謝の気持ちが自然と生まれました
このような関わり合いが広がれば人種主義的な差別や偏見を抑制したり
取り除いたりする社会的な基盤になるのではないでしょうか
共感するということは心で世界をつなぐ作業です
この世界をつなぐという作業は自分が海外に行かなくても移民の歴史を学んだり
外国人住民と関わったりしながら
皆さんが今暮らしている地域社会で実践できます
この実践を通して私たちの教官は
共に生きることつまり強制につながっていくでしょう
冒頭でお伝えしたように私は幼い頃
宇宙人になりたい月がありました
今の私は
地球でそして地域社会で生きていますが
この生き方もまんざらではないと思っています
地域社会は地球の一部ですそして地球は宇宙の一部です
その意味では
地域社会で生きるということは
宇宙の中で生きるということでもあります
このような地域社会で生き続けていくうえでは
国籍やルーツといった千匹にとらわれず
他社に共感しながら生きていくことが何よりも大切だと思います
宇宙に
国境はありません
[拍手]